the only way the planet dies in 30
minutes or less today
is if some man
who has control of thousands of nuclear
weapons decides today is the day
today on Chalk radio the greatest threat
to human existence
and what people like you and me can do
about it I often hear people say
they can't imagine that nuclear weapons
would ever be used because it's a mutual
suicide pact yeah well it's important to
remember we use nuclear weapons we've
already used them twice right so this is
not something that's never happened it's
something that's happened which should
indicate that it can happen again
I'm Sarah Hansen and in this first
episode of season four we're talking
about course
8s271 nuclear weapons history and future
prospects as well as the MIT nuclear
weapons education project which is a
collection of open materials for
lectures and discussions about what
nuclear weapons are and their effects
so why is MIT teaching about nuclear
weapons and why is it important that
people like you and me know about them
to help explain all this I sat down with
two of the course instructors one a
physicist and the other a policy expert
there's still thousands and thousands of
nuclear weapons deployed by the major
powers and the use of even a very small
fraction of them would frankly end Life
as We Know It On Earth it would end life
but the idea was to try to bring this
issue that we think is existential to
the attention of young MIT students and
both undergraduates and graduate
students to
get them interested in and working to
continue the efforts that had been going
on at MIT to try to get rid of nuclear
weapons that was our motivation
that's Bob redwine MIT Emeritus
professor of physics and contributor to
the MIT nuclear weapons education
project
in 1939 the first controlled nuclear
action took place and this was a real
Revelation in many ways to scientists in
Europe and the United States there was a
lot of worry among scientists one fear
that became very real to many scientists
was that Hitler and the Nazis would get
access to this huge energy release that
we now know as nuclear weapons before
the allies during the second world war
so there was a big push to have the
Allies develop nuclear weapons in case
the Nazis were going to develop them
first and that was what led to the
Manhattan Project that eventually led to
the two explosions in Japan
correspondent that air headquarters on
Guam say there is reason to believe that
the Japanese city of Hiroshima
approximately the size of Memphis or
Seattle or Rochester New York no longer
exists on August 6 1945 the United
States dropped a nuclear bomb on the
Japanese city of Hiroshima
three days later on August 9th a second
bomb was dropped this time on the city
of Nagasaki
hundreds of thousands of people were
killed it was total Destruction
it spent nearly 80 years since these
attacks which remained the only use of
nuclear weapons in armed conflict
even so following the bombing of Japan
many many more nuclear arms were created
by the United States and the Soviet
Union
the planet fundamentally changed in the
summer of 1945
that's Jim Walsh senior research
associate at the MIT security studies
program
we invented this awful technology
and then our chief adversary the Soviet
Union who we thought was trying to take
over the world they got it too
our first impulse was to build and build
and build and build both sides
approaching something like eighty
thousand total nuclear weapons between
the two sides as Carl Sagan said it was
like two people sitting in a basement
filled with gasoline one had seven
thousand matches one had eight thousand
they argued over who had more matches
what happened was for the first time in
human history for the first time in
planetary history
humans built a technology that could
destroy everything on Earth there are
many challenges that we face that could
pose an Extinction threat climate change
and other things that will play out over
time but the only way the planet dies in
30 minutes or less today
is if some man
who has control of thousands of nuclear
weapons decides today is the day
Jim explained some of the ways that the
course goes beyond the basic physical
science of nuclear weapons
he highlighted the cultural political
and psychological implications of their
existence and how for a long time the
fact that countries like the US and the
Soviet Union were stockpiling nuclear
weapons was of great concern to people
all over the globe both Jim and Bob
remember the days when nuclear
Armageddon was one of the most common
fears of the General Public
I can remember in grade school we used
to have regular air raid drills where
suddenly the alarm would go off and you
wouldn't be told to rush out into the
corridor between classrooms and put your
head between your knees up against the
wall until you were told to stop and
it's not obvious how much good that
would do during a nuclear explosion but
that was what you know the country was
accustomed to doing during the second
World War
and this tension of living in fear of
nuclear weapons came to a peak in the
1960s during the Cuban Missile Crisis
when the U.S government warned of a
potential nuclear attack by the Soviet
Union from Cuba I happen to be in high
school a few miles away from Washington
DC in Northern Virginia there was a time
like on the order of a week or two when
we weren't sure exactly what was going
to happen Washington D.C was clearly a
possible Target for such nuclear weapons
it was frankly terrifying and we thought
today might be the last day of Our Lives
Jim explained that this fear the thought
of nuclear attacks and Global Extinction
eventually led to action
at least two periods in global history
in the late 1950s and again in the
mid-1980s citizens and governments were
sufficiently
scared that they made changes they
actually destroyed the nuclear weapons
they built they put themselves on a path
where things were safer rather than more
dangerous
but this progress while meaningful was
short-lived
then the end of the Cold War game and we
sort of all forgot about it
but as Bob went on to explain the threat
hasn't disappeared if anything it's in
it's
increased
there are currently many thousands of
nuclear weapons deployed as I think many
of you know the power of a typical
deployed nuclear weapons now on average
is much greater than it was in Hiroshima
and Nagasaki if you had one of these
powerful nuclear weapons exploding let's
say at a city there would be enormous
physical destruction it was enormous and
Hiroshima and Nagasaki would be even
more and many many hundreds of thousands
of people killed there would also be a
huge radiation problem that would spread
much beyond the initial destruction site
that would kill in a reasonably short
time many more people okay from the
radiation in addition there would be a
serious long-term radiation and climate
change issue spreading around the earth
from this explosion over the months and
years following that explosion that's if
there were just one explosion if we had
20 to 50 explosions of this sword
anywhere on Earth it would basically end
Life as We Know It On Earth and we've
got thousands of weapons deployed and
ready to go
I often hear people say
they can't imagine that nuclear weapons
would ever be used because it's a mutual
suicide pact yeah well it's important to
remember we use nuclear weapons we've
already used them twice
you know as a political scientist who
studies deterrence and the possible
deployment of nuclear weapons let me
remind listeners it's been U.S policy to
use nuclear weapons first in a normal
conventional conflict throughout the
Decades of the Cold War just as we fret
today that Russia might introduce
nuclear weapons because they're losing a
conventional War a war of tanks and
artillery and that sort of thing that
was the U.S Doctrine so all during the
Cold War the U.S Doctrine was the
Russian the Soviets had more tanks and
stuff than we did along the European
front we didn't have enough men and arms
to repel a massive Invasion so if they
invaded us with their tanks and guns and
we started to lose we'd use nuclear
weapons that is our policy the current
policy of the United States its current
nuclear Doctrine is counter Force it's
not mutually assured destruction it's
that we're going to hit you first and
try to take out all your nuclear weapons
so that you don't hit us an incredibly
dangerous and destabilizing policy it's
not I'll hit you back if you hit me it's
I'm coming after you because I think I
can get you first so imagine how the
adversary feels in them
these are just simple human beings like
you and me it's not like the human race
has matured and it's suddenly wiser just
because we happen to invent something
that could kill everything no we
basically shoved that technology into
our normal way of thinking about things
we built tons and tons of nuclear
weapons they did the same we had lots of
tests they did the same because it was
considered a normal instrument in a
fight between two adversaries with the
occasional second thought oh my God are
we on the verge of killing everything
while all of this is terrifying it's
also why the MIT nuclear weapons
education project and the course 8s271
were created
and why they're shared on MIT open
courseware the more we understand
nuclear weapons and their effects the
better equipped will be to advocate for
their dismantlement
much of the course is built around class
discussion the instructors focus on
developing students understanding of the
technology and the political context in
which decisions about the technology are
being made
nuclear weapons is a topic that invites
an interdisciplinary approach when we
try to understand the choices that
humans have made about nuclear weapons
we need to understand what are their
political interests what's the nature of
the international competition they find
themselves in what about bureaucratic
battles I think morally it's a pretty
easy decision I don't think anyone ever
has or will have the right to extinguish
life on Earth I don't think any human
has that but as a policy matter I can
imagine their debates and so for example
if Russia uses nuclear weapons in
Ukraine
should the U.S respond with nuclear
weapons
I would say the majority of the class
said no we shouldn't use nuclear weapons
because Russia doesn't I'd be inclined
to agree with that but let's you know
let's be honest let's say we don't does
that encourage Russia to use them a
second time does it send a message to
other countries that they can use
nuclear weapons with impunity very few
of these
choices in the nuclear domain or without
trade-offs and challenges and so we have
to be honest about that as we teach the
course and let students put their chips
on what they think is the best path
forward
and herein lies may be the most
important aspect of the course
showing students and really all of us
that we do have a say in our future with
nuclear weapons
I think we collectively as humans have
no choice but to try to get rid of all
nuclear weapons because as we've
discussed they do pose such an
existential threat it's not easy given
the current situation I think we have to
do the best we can to educate people who
are not experts about the dangers and to
encourage them to vote and to influence
their leaders in the right direction
anyone under the age of 50 has not lived
a minute not 60 seconds in a world where
all around them the most important issue
of the day was nuclear weapons you've
never experienced that for decades we've
been told it's the government's job as
if the governments that own nuclear
weapons are going to get rid of their
own unless they're pushed not likely
but when you say that for a decade after
decade and the memory Fades then you
find yourself in the position we are
today everyone thinks it's a terrible
problem no one thinks they can do
anything about it and that is a problem
in their heads the only thing that
prevents us from doing it is the
decision we make
and so if we make a different decision
then we'll get a different outcome but
that's the challenge it's the it's the
psychological challenge that's the
toughest when it comes to nuclear
weapons and that's why it's important to
remember that we've had success and we
can be successful again
[Music]
teaching or learning with materials from
the MIT nuclear weapons education
project or from the course
8s271 nuclear weapons history and future
prospects please visit our website at
ocw.mit.edu you'll find all the
materials there and as always they're
free and licensed for adaptation
you can help others find the materials
too by subscribing to the podcast and
leaving us a rating and review
if you enjoyed this episode you might
also want to check out our episode from
season one of chalk radio nuclear gets
personal with Professor Michael Short
near the end of the episode Professor
short answers nuclear science questions
posed by open courseware users
until next time signing off from
Cambridge Massachusetts I'm your host
Sarah Hansen from MIT opencourseware
MIT chalk radio's producers include
myself redpachi and Dave leshansky show
notes for the episode were written by
Peter Chipman the 8s271 nuclear weapons
history and future prospects and the MIT
nuclear weapons education project online
Publications were shared on MIT open
courseware by Eliza rienzo we're funded
by MIT open learning and supporters like
you
open courseware will always be free and
open for you to learn anytime anywhere
millions of people learn with ocw
resources each month and none of it
would be possible without the generosity
of ocw users who give back when they can
we hope you'll consider making a
donation to help power free and open
resources from MIT for Learners like you
thank you for your support